(musiikkia)
- Pirjo täällä, hei. Suomi on todella kotiväkivallan, koulun väkivallan ja työpaikkaväkivallan suuri kesk.
Hävettää kerta kaikkiaan katseella noita kansanedustajien istuntoja.
Ei minkäänlaisia käytöstapoja oppositiolla määrätyillä henkilöillä. Ammattitukinto puuttuu monelta ja yhitiökorvauksia saa kaikesta kissan koolesta.
Orpo ja Purra, te olette eduskunnassa todellakin henkisen joukkoraiskauksen uhkia. Telotteenne ovat todella sadistia ja saalistajia.
Eikö sinne eduskuntaan todellakaan saa minkäänlaisia käytöstapoja?
On aika todeta jälleen perinteisesti eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tämän puolituntisen piknikkorista paljastui ainakin työtä, sotea ja onpa luvassa myös hieman alkoholiakin.
Ohjelman seremoniamestarinna toimii Koiviston Lauri. Yksi kansalainen toteaa menon maassamme olevan kuin DDR:ssä. Toinen taas kertoo ettei kehysriihi ole tarpeeksi kestävä ja ehdotetaanpa myös -
että äänioikeus pitää ottaa pois yli seitsemänkymmentäviisi vuotiailta. Ja nyt Maunolla on asiaa.
Niin sen vähemmän on tekemätöntä työtä, mutta tekemätöntä työtä on maailmassa vaikka kuinka paljon ja kaikkea ei ole vielä tehdittykään, kun on tätä tekoälyvä ja aina uusia ja erilaisia värkejä. Ja jos on vain kysyntää tuotteille ja palveluille, niin sieltä löytyy sitä tekemätöntä ja uutta työtä tuohomme kaikki.
Ja ainakin me Vappu marssillaan saamme marssia työn tahdissa. Ja jos tämä ohjelma esitetään ennen Vappua, niin hyvää Vappua kaikille Vapun viettäjille Kantan rapiota kuunnellessa. Kiitos.
Aalto yliopiston Vappu Radion tekijöille. Vieraillimme parisen viikkoa sitten heidän lähetyksessä yhdessä kollegani Lassan kanssa kertoilemassa Kansan radiosta. Oli hieno kokemus. Kiitos vielä siitä. Nyt jatkamme tässä jaksossa työteemalla, johon Mauno meidät jo kuljettikin.
Ja on Kaleita. Kaleita pohjoisesta Terita. Siinä Erasuova puhutti mieleensä, kun Kaleivi tuota. Mistäs hän nyt onkaan? Josakin Vaasaseulta. Ilman se kärkevä mielipiteensä on kyllä täysin hänen mielipidettään vastaan, mutta eikö ole tärkeää, että meillä on tämä demografia, joka mahdollistaa tämmöisten ajatukset. Niillekin annetaan sijaa, että se on sitä oikea demografia. Mutta yksi minkä on huomannut Kansan radiosa on aihe, mistä ei.
Anneta puheenvuoroa, elikkä silloin, jos puolustetaan hallitusta ja sitten tavallaan näistä hallitusta, säästöjen miten onko ne oikeudenmukaisia vai ei, niin siitä mä olen sillä hallituksen kanssa samaa mieltä, että nämä edun saajat on opetettu siihen, että raha kasvaa kuin puussa. Onko he ansainneet sen, että ne ei esimerkiksi tee töitä ja ne saa sitten kumminkin verrattaa hyvän toimeentulon? Minun mielestä pitää todeta.
Pitäisi enemmänkin ottaa ne tue pois ja mahdollistaa kyllä semmoinen kohtuullinen asuminen ja sitten yhteisruokalousainen saisi sen yhden aterian kerrallaan ja jokainenhan pystyy sitten sen jälkeen parantamaan elintasoa minimellä töihin ottamalla vastaan töitä, jos tää tarjotaan. Itse olen ollut työllisyysvalvelussa työhen valmentajana ja olen hyvin tunnu niin lähetä nähnyt tämän, mitä se on osa työttömystä. Tietenkin siellä on niitä helmiäkin, mutta kansalaisten työttömiin pitäisi ottaa vastuun.
- Itse hyvin suurelta osin ja ei maailmalla muuta. Hyvää päivänjatkoa, heippa.
- Vakisääteiseksi, että jos sinä duunarin haet töihin, niin pistä reippaas liksa mitä sille maksetaan. Tää olisi ehdottomasti sääntävä makisääteiseksi, kun täällä säilytetään niin paljon muitakin huonompia lakeja täällä Suomessa. Että kun työnantaja hakee duunaria töihin, pistää siihen joka pennii ja niin paljonko sitä maksetaan.
ja ihmisille mahdollisuuden tulla töihin, niin minun mielestäni työntekijöiden kannattaa ja työttömien kannattaa hakea niihin töihin.
Koska se tuki mitä valtio maksaa, sehän tarkoittaa sitä, että se auttaa sillä hetkellä yli ja heti jos työnantajalta saa jonkun pätkän töitä, niin ottaa sen vastaan.
Siinä on yksi hyvä puoli. Siinä oppii näkemään erilaisia työnantajia ja millä tavalla he toimivat ja ammatillisesti se oma ammattikokemus kasvaa.
Ja mitä enemmän tämmöisiä työuria on, niin työnantaja kunhan hakee uusia työntekijöitä, niin hän arvostaa sitä, että tämä ihminen ottaa näitä töitä vastaan ja sen ammattitaito pysyy.
Ja sitten siinä sivussa alkaa ottaa selvää tämmöisestä asiasta, miten yritystuki ja pienyrittäjät saavat, koska nyt on minun mielestäni selkeästi nähtävissä, että sitä käytetään myöskin hyväksi.
Niin ottakaa selvää nämä työntekijät myöskin siitä, millä tavalla niitä saa ja minkälaisiin tilanteisiin niitä saa. Esimerkiksi jos itse alkavat tekemään näitä pienyrityksiä, millä tavalla te voitte niitä käyttää hyväksi niin kuin kaikki muutkin yrittäjät käyttävät. Jotkut asiallisesti ja jotkut suoraan sanoen hyväksikäyttäen yritystoimintaa. Ottakaa onkeen. Siis mitä tässä maassa oikein tapahtuu? Nyt on aivan erittäin tärkeää.
Tässä on mitta täynnä, kun just luin, että eräs ihminen oli katsottu täysipäiväiseksi yrittäjäksi sen perusteella, että hänellä on nettisivut olemassa, vaikka hänellä ei ollut minkäänlaista yritystoimintaa sillä hetkellä. Viime päivinä olen paljon lukenut näitä aivan älyttömiä. Syynnetään siis ihmisten as bonuksiakin. Joku olisi saanut euro, viiskytkahdeksan senttiä as bonusta, niin se oli johtanut toimeentulotuen uudelleen tarkastukseen, johon oli joutunut.
32 kappaletta liitteitä liittämään. Kenenkään mielestä tämä on järkevää ajan ja resurssien käyttöä? Mitä tämä kaikki maksaa, että ihmisiä kytetään? Tämä on ihan kuin joku DDR-stasi-meininki nykyään tää Suomi. Mitä ihmettä täällä tapahtuu? Ketä tää palvelee? Ihmisiltä yritetään viedä nyt ihan kaikki pienituloisiltakin nujertaa täysin. Nyt koetetaan jaksaa. Ei lannistuta näitten paskiaisten edessä. Kiitos.
...josta olisi voinut rakentaa melkein koko tämän jakson. Nimittäin niin paljon on herättänyt edelleen keskustelua murre-teema. Tällä kertaa ensimmäisenä pääsee ääneen tämän aiheen parisen viikkoa sitten aloittanut soittaja ja hänen jälkeensä lisää kommenttipuheenvuoroja. Ennen niitä kerron vielä, että äsken kuultiin ääniviesti, joka oli lähetetty WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta. Meille Kansanradioon voi lähettää WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tällaisia ...
äänimuotoisia että myös tekstikommentteja. Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551 5464.
Eipä Karjalan edelle mitään pahaa sinne, mutta sitten vähän hänen jälkeensä soitti Oulusta, niin voin sanoa ihan suoraan, että meni iltapilalle kun kuuli sitä Oulun murre. Ei se vaan ihmiskorvallis. Se ei ole soveliaa. Enkä usko, että olen yksin tämän asian kanssa. Puhelu päättyi ihan kun olit kiusalaan puhunut, niin viimeiset puolitoista minuuttia kuunneltiin sitä viensiä käsi sitä savoo tämän aineen täällä. Pitääkö sitä oikein korostamalla korostaa? Se on ihan mahtavaa, että on murteet niitä.
Käyttää, jos on pakko käyttää, mutta ei niitä tarvitse. Ei me etelänkään ihmiset määrä tätä Stadin slangia. Kaikki me puhutaan ihan yleiskieltä täällä. Hyvät ihmiset ymmärtäkään, että teitä ei ymmärretä, jos te viennätte ja kiennätte ja käytätte niitä typeriä omiaan. Mitä kun täällä te haluatte puhumaan tuolla hirveällä murtilasta englantiin, niin ei te mikään ihme, että suomimaine ei kovin hyvä tuolla maailmalla ole. Ei ei ei ei ei näin. Nyt opetelkaa ensin suomi, sitten englantisen jälkeen. Kiitos. Hei.
Ville Joensusta terve. Sille kaverille, joka pari viikkoa sitten vastasti murteita ja kehotti ihmisiä puhumaan kirjakieltä ja semmoisia terveisiä, että pitäisköhän siivota omaa pesään ensin puhtaan sen, niin kuin alkaa muille viisasteiden. Kyseinen henkilö nimittäin käytti termiä kirjakieltä ja suomen kieltä, kun se oikea termi tietenkin olisi suomen kieli tai tai kirjakieli. Vahtaa mennä edellään rypälleet sut usein, kun katsoo seuraavan kerran peiliin. Peilistä tuisivat taikin ihan samanlainen murteiden puhuja.
kun kaikki murteet, joten viepäs kieli keskellä suunta. Murteet on kielen rikkaus. - No heippa. Pari pilkammalla paistaa aurinkoja on muutenkin kiva. Kuuntelin ihan äsken kansanradioja. Mua otti niin auroverkkiin, kun joku oli hirmuärsyntynyt näistä murteista. Ja itse asiassa hänen puheestaan kuuli ihan selvästi joku murre, mutta kun unohdin jo sen, mihin olisin sen sijoittanut, kun on tuo vähän lahunut toimeen yläpää.
Oikein hyvää päivää ja murteita jatkossakin. Moi moi. - Täältä Espoon perukoilta päivää. Tämä herrasmies, joka puhui näistä murteista, että murteet pois, niin samaa mieltä ollaan kyllä täällä Espoossakin. Kaikkien tulisi puhua, kuten täällä ykkösalueella eli pääkaupunkiseudulla puhutaan. Esimerkiksi jokin Turun, Porin tai Tavon murre, niin aivan järkyttävän kuulosta. Samoin myös Oulu ja Tampere. Eihän niistä saa mitään selvää. Kiitos. Hei.
Pirjo, hei. Oli pakko alkaa soittaa, kun joku väläkkymies siellä Kansanradiossa oli sitä mieltä, että kaikkien ihmisten pitäisi puhua kirjakieltä. Höh, sanoin minä. Toivottavasti se oli vitsi ja huono sellainen. Sehän on samaa kuin sanos linnuille, että elenkääpä laulako niin moniäänisesti riittää, kun vaan olis tuo haraka ääni kaikilla. Ei niin. Eläköö erilaiset murteet? Ne on rikasta pääomaa. Kiitos.
Nyt rullailemme rollaattori aiheen pariin. Viime ohjelmamme soittoon tuli useampi kannanotto. Niistä kuullaan kaksi nyt. Niitä edeltää vielä sähköposti toisesta viime jakson aiheesta. Viestissä lukee näin:
tilannetta, että joku on näkymättömissä. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka on lähettänyt esimerkki Melojaukko Pohjois-Karjalasta. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Että jos ei tämä kyseinen henkilö itse osaa ehtiä, niin pyytää jotakin, joka hallihtee vähän etsiä, niin sieltä saa ihan kotimaisen ison rollaattori. Se tulee palaapelin, että sen kasa menee hetki. Mutta kyllä hyvä on ulkokäyttöön tuo, missä on isot ja leveet pyörä, että ei uppototani. Heti viesti päättyy.
Satun tietämään, että sellainen malli on olemassa. Ne ovat sellaisia punaisia ja niissä on just sen kokoiset pyörät, mitä tätä kyseinen herrasmies kaipaili. Ja ainakin Joensuussa näkee hyvin paljon niitä. Ne ovat varmaan paikallisen hyvinvointialueen rollaattoreita, että kyllä niitä on. Niitä pitää vain osaa kysyä. Ratkaisu löytyy tähän. Joo, ja se on ihan käytössäkin tässä maassa. Kiitoksia paljon kun soitit ja kerroit.
Ei.
Näin minä luulen, että tässä asiassa tulee käymään ja en kyllä arvaa mitä sitten Euroopalle noin kokonaisuutena tapahtuu. Eipä sen kummempaa. Hoi, mail on.
En enempää muistaa, mutta varmaan kuulijat jonkun muistaa tämmösiä jo enempi. Joo, hei vaan.
Kotimaan politiikan käänteitä koskevissa puheluissa on vahvana teemana reilu viikko sitten päättynyt kehysrii. No päivää. Uutisten lukija tässä tiedustellei, kun en saanut mitään selvää tuosta hallituksen kehysriihestä, että muistiko ne ollenkaan sitä asiaa, että kun palkankorotukset tulee, että ne leikkaisivat myös niistä omista palkankorotuksistaan. Hei pralan.
Hallitus ottaa sosiaali- ja terveyshuollosta ja sairaalta, johon olisi pitänyt saada lisää rahaa. Siis tekee täysin typeriä ratkaisuja, mutta eihän sitä nykypoliitikonta voisi muuta odottaakaan. Asessiin pannaan kyllä lisää rahaa ja Ukrainan ollaan työntämässä satoja miljoonia ja varmasti 90 miljardtakin tulee vielä aikanaan antajien maksetuksi. Suomi on pistänyt kymmeniä miljoonia droonipuolustuksia ja tännähän ei ole tullut muuta kuin Ukrainan droonia. Siinä on kiitos Suomelle.
Ja siltä tullaan vastinneksi antamaan. Suomen Herrojen jatkuva matkustelu maasta toisi ja vie myös suuria rahamääriä ja siellä tehdyt sopimukset viivät suomalaiset rahat, jotka olisi tarvittu käyttää kotimaasi. Töytöt on pelotettu hiljaisiksi ja Suomen kansa on menettänyt uskonsa tulevaisuuteen. Seuraukset tulevat olemaan hirvitteet, jos tämän maan Herrolle ei saada järkiä päin. Ja kyllä näyttää siltä, että sitä ei tule. Sitä ne menevät yhä vain huonommaksi. Kiitos.
Vanahan Matias tässä kertoo, että tanan kelee, johon on menty aikoihin, kun ei saa enää kuallakaan ilmatteksi. Siitäkin yli kuuskytä euroa revitään, jotta ne saavat leikellä ihmisiä. Kyllä pitää saada ihmisen kualla rauhassa, ettei sitä enää aleta silpomaan ja repimään. Kyllä tuommoiset, jotka ovat keksineet nuo hommat, niille kyllä jotain pitäisi tehdä.
Ei, eihän tuommoinen kehysriisi ole mistään kotosi. Sehän tuuli heittää sen menemään. Täytyy olla kunnolla virsistä rakennettu tukeva kunnon riihi.
Nyt mä oon hirvittää terveysmaksunousu esimerkiksi, että nyt tämän hallituskaran aikana osa on noussut jopa 90 prosenttia. Ja sitten tää terveyskeskusmaksu, sehän kuitenkin ihmiset joutuu ehkä käymään kerran kaksi vuodessa. Nyt se on se alarajaan 20 euroa yhdessä senttiin ja ylärajaan 36 euroa yhdessä senttiin. Ne on aika kova tousnut, jos se on seitsemän kahdeksan euroakin nousee menemään terveyskeskukseen.
Vähävaraiselle. Hirvittää kyllä tää hallituksen toimet. Mikä mielestä se olisi hyvä terveyskeskusmaksu? Kyllä mun mielestä sinne joku pieni maksu on hyvä, ettei ihmiset me ihan turhaa sinne. Mun mielestä se voisi olla joku viisitoista euroa kerta. Sen kyllä ihmiset pystyy maksamaan, mutta jossa joku kolmekymmentä viisi euroa se olisi sitten aika iso summa. Ja tänä päivänä sinne terveyskeskukseen ei niin helposti pääse, koska sinä joututko sinä soita terveyskeskukseen. En juttelet sairaanhoitajan kanssa, sinä jo voi sanoa jotain ohjeita.
Ei välttämättä edes tarvitse mennä terveyskeskukseen. Mitä luulet? Nouseeko nämä sote-asiat ensi vuoden eduskuntavaalien teemaksi jotenkin? Se on ilman muuta, että vaikka nyt tässä kuljenneitten puolueitten puolue tai tämmöisiin valtuustokukouksiin viime maarikkuun vihdeet, se on mun mielestä nyt ihan turha tehdä välikysymys ja työllittää hallitusta kaataa, koska ei ole mitään kaadu. Se on ilman muuta. Kyllä se on ykkösosia ehdottomasti, mutta se mikä on aika mielenkiintoista.
Sitten kun tulee hetken nyt kun annas velkajarrussa, ilmoittaako ne mitä he haluavat? Sitten mistä haluaa säästää? Mä vähän epäilen, ettei se jättu oikein semmoisia kattaväen ilmoituksia. Jäädään seuraamaan, että miten tilanne etenee. Ei mitään. Kiitoksia. Hei hei. Kiitos. Hei hei. Nokkelimmat pokkelimmat saattoivatkin jo arvata äskeisistä puheluista, että seuraavaksi korviin tarjoillaan sote-teemoja. Niitä ennen vielä yksi postikortilla saapunut poliittinen runo.
Persut hallitusta johdettaa. Petteri perässä nyökyttää. Kyllä huomaa, että Sari E:llä on urheilutausta. Hänellä on hyvät niskalihakset. Sano hallituksessa kuka mitä vaan, niin Sarin pää aina nyökyttää. Onneksi Kaisa J. pääsit irti purran purevista hampaista. Tulipa tilalle Ville kaikki tietävä. Eläkeläiset piti jättää rauhaan, mutta tietääkö Ville kuka käyttää kotipalveluita tai asuu palvelutalossa? Onko Ville täysin vähäistä?.
Tällä tavoin luki kortissa, johon on taiteeltu Narsissikolmikko. Kortin oli meille lähettänyt nimimerkki Mökin mummo. Kansanradioon voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiaosoitteeseen Kansanradio pl79 000 24 Yleisradio.
Pikko tän toittelee ja olen nyt sohaisemassa semmoiseen kasa-aikkuuman. Urheilun haluaisin puuttua, että kuinka paljon veromarkkoja käytetään tää kilpaurheiluun, kun siellä on muitakin rahareikia. Nyt olis tää putjat triikin, sais niitä verorahoja sitten sinne käytettyä terveydenhuoltoon. Olisko siellä varaa urheilun puolella kilpaurheilusta nimenomaan.
ottaa vähän varoja siirtää sinne terveelle huoltoon, koska kilpanohjelussa sattuu vielä hyvin paljon loukkaantumisia ja ne tarvitsevat sitä terveellä huoltoa. Liika on liikaa totuut. En mä vastusta mitään kuntourheilua kun kuntoon ei pääse heti kun menee ovesta ulos. Kiitos paljon, heippa.
Helsingin Malmin terveyskeskuksessa mä en saanut apua kun mulla ei ollut tulkkeja kun onkanta suomalainen. Sitten annoin vanhalle rouvalle vuoronumeroni. Me ei tarvittu tulkkeja, mutta tämä lähihoitaja poika Luukula sanoi, että meidän.
Meidän pitää vaan kätsi välisesti odottaa, joten minä lähdin pois ja annoin vuoronumeroni vanhalle rouvalle. Ei kai me turhaan mennä Malmin terveyskeskukseen.
Meidän ohjelmassa ei ole koskaan liikaa seuraavia. Nimittäin nyt kuulemme pari uutta ehdotusta. Ennen niitä on paikallaan muistuttaa, että tutkimus ei tarjota tulevaisuudessa tulevaisuudessa tulevaisuuden tutkimus.
Tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei tarjota tutkimus ei ankkaista tutkimusta ei ankkaista tutkimusta ei.
Ja olen ihmetellyt sitä, miksi ei esimerkiksi vihreät uskalla puhua asiasta, koska erikoisesti heille se kuuluisi. Ja sitten tätä ihmettelen, kun vielä tuetaan tätä lentoliikennettä, vaikka se saastuttaa niin paljon. Tästä verosta tulisi vasti tuloja valtiolle.
Vähän heikosti kuuluu tällä hetkellä, mutta siis kannatat, että Suomeen pitäisi saada kansainvälisille lennoille lentovero, niinkö?
Erikoisesti ja näihin halpalentoihin kaukomaille asti meneviin halpalentoihin, kun he saastuttavat no neella paljon.
Kiitoksia paljon tästä kannanotosta ja oikein hyvää sunnunta jatkoa. Kiitos sitä samaa sinulle.
Pari tässä tervehdys. Tervet terve. Uusi avausaihe, elikkä tuota ehdotukseni olisi se, että yli seitsemänkymmentäviisi vuotiaan tätä äänioikeusta pois. Ja minkä takia näin? Niin, kun ihmiset yleensä äänestävät ikäiseen kun itse ovat.
Elikkä jos me haluamme saada muutoksia, meidän pitää saada nuorempia ihmisiä päättämään. Tällä menolla me ei saada nuorempia päättämään, koska meillä on liian ikäihmisiä siellä eduskunnassa. Nämä päättäjät pitäisi saada muutosta aikaiseksi.
Tää on ainakin itse muistelen, että uusi ehdotus todellakin, että kyllä. Ja tota emmä niin kuin haluan arvostella ikäihmisiä, että ne olisit jotenkin huonoja ihmisiä, vaan kyllä nyt on oikeasti Suomi semmoisessa tilanteessa, että meidän pitää saada muutoksia aikaiseksi.
aikaiseksi ja nuoret eivät ole saaneet tätä lamaa aikaiseksi mutta joutuvat maksamaan siitä. - Olisiko tämä jo nyt seuraavissa eduskuntavaaleissa? - No ei varmasti kattua koska meillä on niin paljon ikäihmisiä ehdokkaina mutta se on semmoinen joka saa varmaan valtaisen raivon Kansanradion kuuntelijoissa mutta me tarvitsemme nyt uusia ehdotuksia, uusia avauksia. Tässä on yksi semmoinen. - Kiitoksia paljon kun toittelee tämän uuden avauksen pöytään. - Katotaan miten käy. Minkälaisia raivopuheluita saat? - Ja jäädään seuraamaan. Kiitoksia paljon.
- Onko kiitokset? Moi. - Nyt on aika syventyä televisiota ja radiota koskeviin kannanottoihin.
Aloitamme teeman WhatsApp-viestillä, jossa lukee näin:
"Hei! Olen samaa mieltä kirrosanojen käytöstä soittaneen sivistyneen rouvan kanssa.
En halua kuulla kirrosanoja kotonani edes laulujen sanoissa, joten joudun sulkemaan radion, kun tiedän niitä olevan tulossa.
Radion toimittajilla on tässä valtaja vastuu."
Tämän tekstin meille on lähettynyt Helena Vatsan viestillä.
Tämä nyt ei ole mikään maailmaa kaatava, mutta ei meitä kaikkia nuo suuren maailman asiat niin kauheasti kosketa.
Nämä pienet lähellä olevat asiatkin voivat olla tärkeitä jossakin. Moikka.
Ja kappaleita niin kuin tämäkin päivänsäde ja mennikäinen, jonka hän sotaa aikana suunnitteli. Ja kaikki ne muut kappaleet, että tuommoista kamalaa rillitusta vaan, että kyllä siellä tiedetään Yleisradiossa, että vanhukset haluaisivat joskus saada niitä vanhoja muistoja. Ei muuta, kiitos.
Ja kolme minuuttia, niin Sari on uutisia, moi.
Vaikeita hommia, esimerkiksi vaikka takapuoli edellä puuhun kiipeämistä. Ja jokaisen tehtävän jälkeen otettaisiin sitten sellainen reipas neljän tai kahdeksan desin kossupaukku edelleen, jatettaisiin tehtäviä niin kauan aikaa. Ja se, joka pystyy sen päivän mittaan tekemään kaikki tehtävät, niin se olisi tosi selviä ja kannattaa haketa. Mä otan kopi haitin tästä, jos joku sen ottaa johonkin.
Hauskaa sunnuntaina kaikille.
Taisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmisvastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Eli sitä ei saa tehdä sitä teeslettä eli sitä teeslata alkoholiksi tai kirkkaankaan alkoholisiin kuin pontikkaari kansankielellä, niin sitä ei saa tehdä. Se on laissa kielletty. Ja tämä selviti sitä, minkä takia se on kielletty, niin se on kielletty sen takia, kun tuota kotona valmistelee, siitä saattaa tulla sokeaksi. Ja mä ajattelin sitä vaan tuota, että jos on valmiiks sokee, niin eiks se sitte oo sallittua.
Ilmat haluat ilua antaa. Ilmaa ja tippaleivät osaa kantaa. Se myös meitä usein kiinnottaa. Elämästä silloin jopa riikuttaa. Luontokin menee hymyille. Vihreys hyvin iloteksi tekee. Riemukin rieltää mieleen, kun kieli osuu rakkaan mieleen. Yhdessä paljon myös rauletaan, eikä kaikkein eniten tanskitaan. Rakkaus tulee usein muukaan.
Kiitä ei vältä oikein kuka, sillä se on rakkauden aikaa. Vaikea vastuhtaa jos rainkaa. Se on myös ihaninta aikaa. Siitä iloa ydänpaljontaa. Hyvin iloiset vaput kaikille toivoo arvolla. Heipä hei!
Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa. Kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä. Hei täällä mumma. Minkä ihmin takia Peter Parkkosen ja Lintan kappale sotkettiin tällä tavalla. Se alkuperäinen oli hyvä ja nyt kun siihen sekoitettiin tää symfoniaorkesteeli niin koko terävyys meni koko kappaleesta. Siinä meni voitto. Selvä. Näin käyttiin. Miksi sählättiin taas? Kiitos. Semmonen homma, että se on nyt mies tältä toteuttaa.
Haluaisin sanoa Suomen kansalle semmosen jutun, että no euroviisu. En ole sitä yhtään kiinnostunut, mutta nyt on kyllä Suomella semmoinen kappale, että ensimmäistä kertaa aion katsoa viisuja, koska olen aika varma, että jos ei se voita, niin kyllä se on siinä kärkipäässä ainakin. Ensimmäistä kertaa katson euroviisut ja sillä selvä, että nyt se vasta mielenkiintoista kerrankin on. Ei muuta. Jo hei!
Hei Kansanradio! Terveisiä Nokialta! Olemme huomanneet ruokakaupoissa ikävän ilmiön. Kaupan asiakkaat ottavat kylmätuotteita ja päätettyään, etteivät halua ostaa kyseistä tuotetta, se jätetään mihin sattuu pitkin kauppaa ajattelematta kylmäketjua laisinkaan. Nämä jätetyt tuotteet päätyvät roskiin. Jatkossa voisitteko laittaa kylmätuotteet kylmää, ettei synny turhaa hävikkijää? Kiitos! Terveisin Satu, Lotta ja Elias.
(Musiikkia)